our presidency comes at a time when the
world's eyes are also on Europe and many
citizens are looking at us to be able to
not only make decisions but also
operationalize them and carry them out
for stability outside our borders
security at our borders and safety
within our borders we simply need a
better European cooperation and stronger
implementation we have the strategic
agenda and it is our task to ensure that
the work continues and especially in
four areas we make progress first of all
of course the issues of migration and
international security we continue
obviously also to work on Europe as an
innovator and job creator moving forward
especially some of the tasks that deal
with the internal market with the
digital market with the energy Union
also sound European finances and a
robust eurozone and last but not least
forward-looking policy on climate and
energy now that we have the cop21 agreed
it is up to also our presidency to move
forward the decisions that have we made
there in terms of translation towards
European and national policies we will
officially launch an apse a challenge to
invite people to help us increase
European Union's transparency I have
great confidence in the creativity and
ingenuity of citizens to surprise us and
to develop an app that gives more
insight into the different layers of
European decision-making and the winner
of this app challenge will be chosen at
a first-ever European transparency camp
and unconference on European
transparency in June in Amsterdam